so I overslept today so far so good
[Music]
sorry
texting Greg what is up reject nations
John Humphrey coming at you day 3 and
we're going strong last night I did a
reaction to a trailer for the Florida
project very much enjoyed that and
looking in the comments everybody is
yelling at me for the same thing John
you got to react to the killing of a
sacred deer this is another movie I know
nothing about judging by the title I
imagine it'll it'll probably be surreal
in some ways uh uh so without further
ado let's get into this we we don't have
to worry about nothing because we got
this all and I'm really sorry no off
shirt
no it is human ears board where you to
come
[Music]
[Music]
if there's an inner cultivation another
it be relative in your face but if
there's never done Jackie Christie will
be a movie where she what to do and why
I should ask my children so they can
play it out oh boy you guys man do you
guys think that I like you guys man I
gotta watch that trailer again hold on a
sec it's hard to know exactly where to
begin on a trailer like this funny
enough the lobster is a movie that I
really wanted to see last year or
whenever exactly that came out it gets
blurry sometimes release dates movie
release date will be early not my forte
when it comes to trivia the lobster was
movie I really wanted to see I ain't get
to see and I'm kicking myself for that
but this guy you're got slammed Tomas he
seems like an incredibly interesting
filmmaker just from the glimpses I've
gotten into his movies thus far as is
his second collaboration with Colin
Farrell right off the bat I mean the
captain this seems great it's cool to
see Nicole Kidman out there rocking it
still after lion and the beguiled and
stuff like that it seems like she's
having a resurgence lately and that's
cool to see I think Colin Farrell is a
great dramatic actor I always really
enjoyed watching him especially in films
like this yeah Barry Cogan Cohen Keoghan
yeah the boy from Dunkirk and the C
story and also from what I can tell an
IMDB Alicia Silverstone is also in this
we'll be so props to her again 8:24
knows how to cut really intriguing
trailers and I'm a big fan of
psychological or like this you know it's
hard for me to grasp exactly what the
story is going to be like the the main
action the plot but from what I can
gather from the logline of this it's
about Colin Farrell's character Steven
he takes this teenage boy under his wing
and then things take a turn for the
sinister and he's got to figure out what
to do about that and I shudder to think
of what that will be like movies like
this really appealed to me I like movies
that take a lot of different elements
and crash them together
this looks equal parts you know family
drama revenge thriller medical drama
stuff like that I don't know what to
make of it but there's this weird like
paralysis thing that it seems like is
making its way to more and more
characters as this trailer goes on I'm a
little bit baffled by this but in a good
way this definitely looks unique and in
time and age where people often bemoan
the lack of originality in cinema I mean
this looks pretty damn original and
surreal and strange and I mean the
performances look great from what I can
tell here and as far as the the slow
stripped back cover song trailer trope
goes I think this is one of the better
versions of that I've seen just having
for this one girl sing it over the
entire trailer I actually think makes
this pretty cool and the thing is
trailers aren't made to be watched a
million times I guess but this just is
the little piece is really cool to me
and the style of this movie is anything
like the trailer which you know you
always hope it will be I got imagine
this is going to be a pretty fascinating
strange befuddling hypnotic if not it if
not if not
kind of movie and all the feelings I get
off of this or just dread tension
uneasiness I like lo-fi science-fiction
a lot and that's kind of what a lobster
from what I've heard is sort of like and
I also like lo-fi horror thrillers and
things like that stuff that takes place
in the real world but it has a very
strange or surreal tone or tambour to it
and that looks like what this is I'm a
big horror buff I like a lot of
different kinds of horror movies and
different styles and approaches but uh
the stuff that usually affects me the
most and of loving the most is this kind
of more human more plausible even if it
has some kind of out there elements
stuff like this usually gets my motor
running this is the kind of trailer I
would like Shawn Humphrey joint to have
sort of if that makes sense this seems
like one of those movies where you're
probably going to watch Colin Farrell
and probably a lot of the other
supporting characters well sort of
spiral into the deep end and you know
those are usually character arcs that
are pretty fascinating this is being
billed as a kind of psychological horror
revenge thriller I can definitely see
that and I am pretty damn excited to see
this movie so thank you guys for
recommending that to me you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or video is up out
everything like that we got tons of cool
stuff on patreon for you guys to check
out come over there join our community
and as always I am John Humphrey Det
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
peace hopi only one iowa is in